your life began the day it nearly ended
we saved you you were reborn
something in my past is the key to all
of this
the floor is just the beginning
I'm not gonna fight your war I'm gonna
end it
everybody is Charlie Happy New Year
Marvel just posted a new Captain Marvel
promo there was some new behind the
scenes and there's some funny stuff that
they're doing with Jude Law's character
there are a couple official Marvel
websites in a couple official licensing
materials that are reporting different
identities for his character so I'll
explain what's going on we talked about
gas lighting how the Kree and the
Skrulls are misleading her about what
our identity is during the film trying
to play her against both sides
Marvel is kind of doing the same thing
in real life with Jude Law's character
it's actually pretty funny but no
worries we'll break it down and because
it's the holidays we're doing a new
round of that IMAX ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Captain Marvel moment on the video
they're cutting some of that new footage
in a slightly different way and you
could kind of tell that they've been
polishing a little bit more like when
she's on this ship here when she's
fighting what looks like these scroll
soldiers that have revealed themselves
you can actually see a foosball table
that's broken off to the left here like
either it's an alien spaceship or it's a
shield base that they've taken over and
it just happens to have all these earth
trappings all around it it definitely
does look like a spaceship but why does
it have a foosball table on it maybe the
scrolls just really like foosball but if
you don't remember the big secret
invasion crossover event that Marvel did
several years ago there were actually a
lot of scrolls during that event that
started being more sympathetic to humans
and they actually started liking doing
human things so it's actually not that
unusual for Scrolls you know advanced
alien race that are trying to take over
the earth from the inside so that they
can invade to actually start liking
things about humans it's the Kree that
feels superior to everyone else
there was another new picture of Jude
Law's character with them on a mission
early in the film this is them when
they're doing Star Force stuff this is
before she comes back to Planet Earth
there's actually a behind-the-scenes
featurette that's playing at Cinemark
theatres too if you go see any movie
there but there's not a whole lot of new
footage and they'll probably post that
online sometime soon but the more
interesting thing really has become the
question about Jude Law's character and
the reason why Marvel misleading you
will become a little more evident when I
explain what's going on Marvel has been
intentionally omitting any reference to
his character in the Captain Marvel
movie it's pretty normal for them
nowadays just to not tell you who's
playing what character when they're
initially cast like you know whole bunch
of famous people in this movie come see
it it's gonna be awesome will tell you
who they're playing
later but usually they save that for the
first two trailers when they reveal who
the main cast is because you actually
see them in their costumes you hear them
talking or if they're playing a
motion-capture character like the black
order during infinity war you can kind
of pick out who's playing who like
Carrie [ __ ] was playing Proxima midnight
pretty easy to identify her voice but
there been about four times in the past
year when there have been reports about
who Jude Law is really playing and
Marvel has wiped every reference to his
character from official marketing
material and web sites but each of those
four times reported him as a different
character which is kind of hilarious so
first time we got it was last fall when
he was initially cast prior to shooting
Variety reported that he was playing
Walter Lawson
that's the secret human persona of
Marvel the original male version of
Captain Marvel from the comics you know
pretty big character a bit of a deep cut
at this point just because we haven't
seen him in the Marvel movies yet but
variety didn't say anything about him
playing the male Captain Marvel they
just said he was playing Walter Lawson
so it'd be like saying Chris Hemsworth
had been cast to play Donald Blake in
the first Thor film he's Thor there's
only a brief reference to his one-time
human persona from the comics Donald
Blake there was a brief joke in the film
about Donald Blake who was Jane Foster's
former boyfriend Thor put his jacket on
for a second so it was just a reference
to Thor's one-time human persona when he
had been banished to Earth by Odin but
for the most part variety is one of the
big Hollywood trades they're like 99%
trustworthy when it comes to breaking
news like this so if they said that he
was playing Walter Lawson that was a
pretty good chance that he was playing a
version of Marvel but then came the
first trailer we got a few shots of him
he had these crazy yellow eyes like yawn
Rob in the comics and a few scenes that
we had seen he comes off as a hard-ass I
mean it doesn't say like a total [ __ ]
because they didn't speak that much so
it's kind of hard to tell but he's
present during the accident that
activates Carol Danvers full Captain
Marvel powers and what looks like their
version of the psyche magnetron here
brie Larson said in the movie that the
accident only enhances what's already
there which implies that she's already
half Cree and they really are following
that prequel comic book story that
Marvel just published last month they
released those first trailers little
wild goes by then gains a toys there was
this giant batch of Funko toys with
everyone in their various costumes like
these are officially
Marvel licensed toys they take a long
time to make they take a long time to
print those toy boxes so of course we
always see those before the actual movie
comes out one of the figures was a yawn
raagh and he was wearing a Star Force
uniform like the other members of Star
Force now keep in mind that they're all
creep but only the members of Star Force
wear these green looking uniforms with
these special helmets so that meant that
jaan raghav Star Force and previously
Marvel had already revealed who all the
members of Star Force were this is Carol
Danvers this is Gemma Chan playing min
Eva this is Atlas this is bran char and
this is Korath who you remember from the
guardians of the galaxy movie Ronan the
accuser is a big part of the movie but I
don't think he's technically a member of
Star Force so Jude Law was the only
character that marble hadn't officially
confirmed so everyone just naturally
assumed that the mystery Yan rock star
force character was Jude Law he's an
[ __ ] in the comics he's got crazy
yellow eyes it all fits Jude Law playing
Yan drog until this week when the
official Marvel website for the film
listed him as walter lawson marvel so
people like well if Marvel is saying on
their website that he's officially
Marvel then that must be what's going on
but after the news outlets and all the
blogs picked it up Marvel quickly
deleted the reference from the website
and said nothing about the matter right
now the website just lists him as the
leader of Star Force so here's the thing
marple usually doesn't lie on their
websites about who characters are like
it's like the most broad version of a
wiki that you've ever seen ego the
Living Planet was listed as ego no fake
name or anything like that the Bunco
toys that marble licenses for the movies
also do not lie so this really is a yawn
raagh character in the film that this
toy is based on he's a core part of the
Carol Danvers origin story it makes
sense that they would put him in the
movie right as I was making this video
to just in the last day there was a
Marvel Legends toy that just released
also listing him as yon rock and it
actually had a much better description
in a backstory for his character too
that confirms Kree supreme intelligence
in the movie so it just says on the back
of this card here leader of Star Force
team jaan raghav ero among the Kree in a
key asset to the supreme intelligence in
the war against the scroll
Jude Law separately said he's driven by
a belief in the divine leadership of the
Cree people he's almost a devout warrior
unquestioning conservative but
inspirational if you've ever read the
comics in the Kelley sued iconic marvel
run that this is based on I would not
call a Yan Rock inspirational or devout
warrior like he seems more like a mad
scientist that just interested in
experimenting on people in the psyche
magnetron that gave Carol Danvers her
powers is really just a device to do
that like it's literally meant to unlock
huge powers and people but the device is
forbidden technology because it's so
powerful so unpredictable and so
dangerous so of course jaan raghav a
villain so he doesn't care about any of
those things and uses it anyway
if Marvel says on their official website
that he's playing Marvel the original
Captain Marvel in Funko in the Marvel
Legends official licensed toy lines are
saying that he's Yad raagh and neither
of them are lying what does it mean
about his character this is like a ninth
level Marvel mystery here we haven't had
that many Marvel mystery movies it
probably means though Jude Law is
playing both characters and ultimately
by the end of the film he's either
revealed to be yon Robin just
masquerading as Marvel this whole time
where it's also double twisty and he's a
scroll who's been masquerading as yon
rock and Marvel in a bid to infiltrate
the Kree Empire and ko out to resources
like Captain Marvel to destroy the Kree
from within but that seems a little more
twisty I think it's more likely that
he's jaan raghav like the actual Captain
Marvel villain but they've given him a
persona that's closer to Marvel in the
comics and maybe they just include a
reference to that name because they did
imply that there was a romance between
their two characters they also did
clarify that her powers are cosmic level
there aren't that many cosmic level
beings in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that we've seen so far
ego the Living Planet you know aka
celestial is probably the best example
of that just crazy powers that we hadn't
seen on a galactic scale prior to the
infinity gems in the Infinity Gauntlet
but even though there's a big question
about exactly how powerful MCU Captain
Marvel is I would say you know she's on
the level of like Stormbreaker breaking
Thanos his skin while he's wearing the
full Infinity Gauntlet the reason the
Russo said that Thor was able to get fan
O's with storm breaker
was only because Thanos was caught
unawares if he were fighting them in a
more direct battle and he had more time
to study how the Infinity stones will
work and how best to use them then they
would have no chance which i think is
why it's gonna be a more interesting
fight during avengers endgame when they
have a rematch with him because at every
turn like even when he's fighting the
Hulk at the beginning of infinity war he
takes his armor off and that's really
badass armor just because he wants to
have fun fighting the Hulk and he wasn't
even using the power stone when he was
fighting him so keep in mind that that's
just the beginning of how badass Thanos
is so I think Avengers endgame is
actually the fulfillment of the promise
of the best version of a fight that you
could expect between Thanos at full
power and the Avengers at full power
with the addition of Captain Marvel let
me know in the comments what do you
think is going on with Jude Law's
character if Marvel is both reporting
him on official material as Y on Raw and
as walter lawson AKA marvel from the
comics what'll happen is is because I'm
travelling I'm actually recording this
in like the weirdest possible way you
guys have no idea what this looks like
while I'm recording this video it's
hilarious I'll be back home on Sunday so
videos will be back to normal but I have
more Marvel to post more Game of Thrones
and some new Rick and Morty season 4
that's actually pretty cool so I'll name
a giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
but leave all your video requests in the
comments below I'll be posting videos
through New Year's so there will be
holiday videos as well there was a
really cool talk that Kevin Feige gave
that I put in my Avengers end game
teaser video click here to listen to him
talk about all that stuff it's actually
really cool and click here for my Once
Upon a Deadpool a new post-credit scene
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]